This week the world's going to have to invest in about 14
trillion dollars worth of grade in order to accommodate all the
capacity that's going to be put on. Connecting the dots to turn
on the lights. If countries around the world want to meet their
renewable targets they're going to need a reliable way to
deliver clean energy. We look at some of the solutions. The
United States simply doesn't have the same kind of transmission
infrastructure to move power around. And that's really going to
be a problem going forward. The United States is in the midst of
an energy transition. But how do we move an entire country's
power grid from fossil fuels to a cleaner alternative. What
we're contributing here is the potential to grow. So essentially
no one is left behind in the race to development in the race to
making our energy more green. And what about people off the
grid. We'll look at one company helping rural communities power
themselves.
I'm Kailey Leinz and this is Bloomberg Daybreak.
Nearly half of the world's electricity will come from renewable
energy by 2050 as costs of wind solar and battery storage
continue to plummet. But creating clean energy is only half the
battle. The other half comes from how we transfer it from where
it's produced to where it's needed. Electrical grids are getting
old in the U.S. parts are over a century old. Despite its age
it's surprisingly reliable with a few notable exceptions. This
morning the power crisis in Texas entering its fourth painful
day and these exceptions are likely to increase with more demand
and pressure from climate change.
Our current model of electricity generation and transmission
works a little like a waterfall. The generator sets the top be
at fossil fuel powered nuclear hydro or from renewables.
The electricity flows down into substations that use
transformers to convert the energy into practical voltages which
sends it by a wire to homes and businesses.
Sensors monitor how much electricity goes where and meters on
the back end record how much gets used.
This incredibly simplified portrait of electrical grids shows
how all energy flows in one direction. It's a top heavy
centralized power structure. But the proliferation of renewables
are allowing end users to generate their own electricity and in
some cases surpluses that can be sent back to the grid. These
areas are called micro grids islands of self-contained power or
ideally decentralized generators connected into a larger grid
system.
How to regulate all this power flying up and down over massive
transmission network is a huge policy issue right now. In the
U.S. federally regulated central generators sell power in an
auction market to distributors which are generally regulated by
states with more small generators coming online. It's unclear if
this patchwork approach is going to work and doubtful that it
would be the most efficient system. Another aspect of renewables
to reckon with is that optimization for these power sources
often situates them in locations far from the final customer.
This differs from older fossil fuel power stations that were
built closer to municipalities. Offshore wind farms are the
perfect example.
How do we move the power generated back onshore at reasonable
cost. Moving electricity is a little like trying to run with a
bucket full of water. Some electricity is lost during
transmission in the form of heat which compounds over long
distances. One solution that's being proposed is essentially a
big bucket. Giant ultra high voltage direct current cables that
would connect power grids internationally. An added advantage
would be that renewables if given transmission capacity could
power the dark side of the earth. While the flip side isn't
sunshine further reducing our reliance on fossil fuels refined
cost energy the cost of building this massive infrastructure
project will be huge and regulating it will take perhaps more
international cooperation than ever seen before. Well ever since
President Xi Jinping pitched the idea of a global energy
internet to the United Nations six years ago China has been
trying to persuade the world to build high voltage highways that
would form its backbone. That plan to wrap the planet in a web
of Intercontinental made in Beijing power lines has gone pretty
much nowhere.
But the fortunes of so-called super grids appear to be turning
just maybe not on the scale she first envisioned. Joining me now
is Mark Champion Bloomberg senior reporter for International
Affairs who has been covering this story for us. So China's all
over this. Why. And should that concern anyone.
Well it's a good question. I mean the main reason why China has
done it is that they had to develop this that grid at such a
pace just because of the scale of growth in China over the last
couple of decades.
And they were trying to knit together some pretty shaky grids in
order to really get power to all those factories that were
manufacturing everything for the world.
And more recently what they've started to do is to say hey if we
have a large renewable energy solar or wind plant that farm this
growing debate producing electricity out in Tibet. So what
they've done is to develop these really long lines longer than
anyone else has developed before at higher voltages that anyone
else has developed before. And they've connected them up as to
whether anyone should be worried. I mean it's a it's a very good
question. What China's saying is we need to build these grids
all over the world. So first of all that's a pretty good
commercial proposition for China. They'll do very well in terms
of trade. And then secondly it raises questions you know who's
going to control this global grid. Who's going to set the
standards you know and does that matter. And for some people it
does say they worry that it will be a little bit like when the
U.S. built the global financial system after World War Two. And
that you know it's not like the US owns the financial system the
global financial system everybody takes part in. And yet it gave
the US enormous influence. And we've discovered that more and
more quite recently. So there's some concern about that. These
ideas aren't new. They have been around for a long time but
there were barriers in the past to getting them built at scale.
Why would this time be different.
Yeah absolutely. These things are not popular. These are huge
cables. Often they're overground and they have to go through a
lot of people's backyards. So it's not popular for that reason.
Very difficult. More difficult in a democracy where people get
to decide whether they want them going overhead. And you know on
top of that you know countries on generally crazy about
volunteering to depend on another country for electricity with
oil. If you don't have oil and you kind of have to you have to
buy your oil from Saudi Arabia or the US or elsewhere with
natural gas. You may have to buy it from Russia because you
don't have your own. But with electricity you know you can build
your own plant. Everybody's got some sun. Everybody's got some
wind. Some have more than others. But you can do it yourself. So
in general it hasn't been absolutely necessary. It was something
that for example the European Union did after the war to build a
sort of more competitive a bigger grid. And it's good for making
sure that as with Texas this winter if you have some major
problem in your grid you can turn on the tap from another one.
Embarrass my electricity by some electricity and it means that
you don't have to shut off the lights. What's changed now is
that with renewables you know if you have a big coal plant you
can just sit it next to the city you want to serve. If you have
renewables you know off offshore like the U.K. has been building
some huge offshore wind plant farms in the North Sea. If you if
you want to develop that you can't do it next to London. You
have to put your offshore wind where the wind is which in this
case is offshore. If you look at just how much
the climate targets imply that countries are going to have to
increase the amount of electricity that they produce and to
generate well they're going to have to get that from somewhere.
A lot of it will be micro produced on people's roofs and small
utility plants close to cities. But that probably isn't going to
be enough. So if I'm looking for renewable energy solutions are
cables. My answer that one answer and not everybody believes
that they are the you know the best answer for some. There are
kind of old school old think way of producing energy because
this kind of centralized you know that the Chinese love this
because it's centralized. You can control it centrally. You
build a huge utility scale power centers which are a little bit
like a renewable nuclear plant or a renewable coal plant. But
for others you know there's there's greater interests security
efficiency in producing really micro generation and connecting
those and smart grids. So there's there's different ideas about
how this is going to pan out. But the sort of consensus is you
kind of need it all. The amount of power that we're going to
need to generate in addition to what
I think Bloomberg new energy finance is estimated that the
world's going to have to produce invest in about 14 trillion
dollars worth of grid in order to accommodate all the capacity
that's going to be put on. And some of that is likely. It's
pretty certain and we can see it happening now that it's going
to be these big cables. The question is how much. All right.
Mark Champion Bloomberg senior reporter for International
Affairs. Thank you so much. And you can read Mark's Business
Week piece in full on your terminal or on Bloomberg dot com.
Coming up the road to clean energy. We all know we need to get
there. But how. We'll speak to author Russell Bowles on how to
take the next steps on the path to green. Plus we've looked at
super grades but what many grades. We'll explore the sustainable
energy solutions powering rural communities. This is Bloomberg
Daybreak.
This is Bloomberg. GREENE I'm Jennifer's ambassador in New York
with your Green Brief.
The G7 is dropping its target for electric vehicles. Instead
it's now only pledging to speed up efforts to phase out the
combustion engine. But it didn't set firm dates. The communique
at its latest summit was much more modest than some of the
earlier versions under discussion.
Oil giant Shell is planning to speed up its plan to cut
emissions. It follows a ruling from a Dutch court saying the
firm's plans weren't good enough. Shell still plans to appeal
but says it also wants to rise to the challenge posed by the
decision. Shell is also eyeing a possible sale of its holdings
in the largest U.S. oilfield.
Swiss voters shot down a plan to reduce the nation's carbon
footprint. They rejected a higher levy on CO2 emissions after
claims the measure was too costly. The government is now heading
back to the drawing board in order to meet its commitment to the
Paris climate deal. And that's your green it brief.
Thanks Jen. Well with the rise of solar wind and other renewable
energy sources humanity is racing along a path towards clean
energy. We're already producing more and more of it but there's
plenty of barriers to overcome to get it where it needs to be.
Our next guest is Russell Galt and he started the push to
renewables in his book Super Power One Man's Quest to Transform
American Energy. Russell great to talk to you. So the issue is
that you can create energy you can harness it then you have to
transport it. Is that the biggest pain point.
Absolutely. It's one of the largest problems right now in the
deployment of renewables. The United States the middle of the
United States the plains are an incredible wind resource. The
Southwest is an incredible solar resource. But that's simply not
where people are where industry is. And moving the electricity
that can be generated there at extraordinarily low cost to the
coasts where most people live is just incredibly difficult. We
don't have the infrastructure right now and we're really
struggling to build it. What does the infrastructure have to
look like.
Well we're talking about our large transmission lines mostly
D.C.. I wrote about a group of entrepreneurs that were trying to
build a direct current line. I mean this is what's happening in
China. It's what's happening in Germany. And the United States
simply doesn't have the same kind of transmission infrastructure
to move power around. And that's really going to be a problem
going forward in the United States because it's going to be more
difficult to get access to the extraordinarily inexpensive
renewables. And a bigger grid means that the grid is more
robust. And frankly it means it's more protected from things
like hack or any kind of other national security intrusion. But
if the electricity itself is inexpensive is investing in this
kind of distribution infrastructure expensive it cost a lot of
money to build transmission lines. We're talking in the billions
of dollars but every single person who's looked at this from
from a bigger picture economic point of view says that that
investment pays back many times over. So let's talk about
investment. Obviously the Biden administration has outlined its
goals for long term economic spending kind of a question mark as
to how much of that will actually be realized. But from what
you've seen. Does it go far enough.
It's a huge step in the direction of creating incentives for
private industry to want to build these transmission lines. We
wanted the biggest ideas that's out there is a transmission tax
credit. However it's not just about money to build a
transmission line is extraordinarily difficult. It is many times
more difficult than to build something like a natural gas
pipeline. A similar piece of infrastructure in the United States
makes it so much easier to build a berry pipeline in terms of
eminent domain in terms of streamlining the process. Building
transmission is just extraordinarily difficult and it's not
because we want to make it more difficult. What can the U.S.
learn from other countries in that respect.
Well I think you know getting back to this question of
streamlining one of the things that I think would be incredibly
important is that right now if you go to a place like Germany if
you go to a place like China if you want to build. I mean
obviously in China there's there's no you know it's state run.
But in Germany if you want to build a transmission line you have
to meet certain environmental certain social hurdles. You know
you have to sort of prove that there's transmission line is what
will not disturb too many people et cetera. But you have
ultimately a regulator you can go to to get that answer. In the
United States you don't. There's no one that will really give
you a final answer. And that's why the decisions get stretched
out for five or 10 years. Well when you're a private industry
and you're trying to get investors and you're saying to well we
really won't know if we can make it go this for five or 10
years. That's that's the kiss of death. It's not going to work.
And so what the United States could learn from other countries
is to have a process where if you want to build transmission
here's what you can do and you'll get a yes or no answer. Does
this make sense. Is this in the national interest and you'll get
it within a certain timeframe. Two or three years seems
reasonable to me. That's what the United States could learn from
other countries that are doing this more successfully. All
right. Russell Gold author of Super Power One Man's Quest to
Transform American Energy. Thank you so much.
Coming up how do you bring people out of poverty without
wrecking the climate in the process. We'll explore how one
company is helping rural communities power themselves
their green.
From Bloomberg's headquarters in New York I'm Kelly Lines and
this is River Green. Well a rural village in Kenya might not be
the first place you'd expect to find electric motorcycles
Internet service and thriving local businesses. But a solar
powered mini grid is making it all possible. U.S. based energy
startup Power Hive is on a mission to supply clean energy to
rural communities around the world bringing economic opportunity
without the need for fossil fuels.
In Africa six hundred and fifty million people don't have
electricity don't have access to power don't have access to
industry. People who would otherwise have been very productive
if they'd had the means if they had the capital.
It's really important that we don't lose sight of these people
in our bid to grow our economies and become more industrialized.
One of the toughest problems in the world is how do you bring
people out of extreme poverty without wrecking the climate in
the process. Conventional wisdom says it will require the
burning of enough fossil fuels to cancel out any progress. The
developed world makes on emissions.
But here in rural Kenya a small experiment is underway to see if
it's possible to have the economic uplift without the
environmental catastrophe.
Power is the first privately licensed utility in Kenya.
We currently operate about 25 village level micro grids or
generating power from solar. Restoring that energy in batteries.
When I started in this business 20 years ago the price per watt
of a solar panel was five six dollars. Now it's 20 cents.
It's opened up a huge opportunity in Africa to deliver energy.
A micro mini grid like the ones built by Power Hive is a power
system that supplies enough electricity for small community
schools and homes get electric light and Internet service.
Agricultural labor like maize milling doesn't have to be done by
hand anymore.
Electric pressure cookers eliminate the need to chop down trees
or burn charcoal to make meals. All of these things raise the
standard of living. But there's one big problem.
When we first came into Kenya we quickly realized that our
consumers are too poor to pay for energy.
Many Brits have been around for a long long time. The problem is
is that there hasn't been economic models to support the long
term operations of these crowds.
It forced us to have to think about how we can support our
customers in generating enough income that they can sustain
themselves and then also create a good energy customer for us as
a business. In most rural communities in Kenya subsistence
farmers would keep maybe 20 chicken and these would be primarily
for eggs. They might sell or consume themselves really. But
electricity along with some startup capital from Power Hive has
changed. All plant powered appliances like heat lamps and
incubators can transform chicken rearing into a profitable
business.
It's a virtuous cycle for power hive. They give their customers
the money and guidance to start businesses that use their
electricity and then a portion of the income from those
businesses pays for the electricity. Mama mama put out the book.
It couldn't be done about that. I'm buying a tidy up from a
lovely design. I'll start there now. It's not done on junk food.
Not both of them are not good people. Metric. I took on an old
idea. Well not if you thought the CAC. You know become a kid by
RTS up one of the candidates.
You also find the community members who do see successful
businesses get inspired to do that themselves. And all of that
wouldn't have happened if they hadn't had the exposure or
understood how it can be done or that it can be done.
Recently Power Hive has invested in a new business leasing
electric vehicles to people in the villages and in nearby Casey
town.
My name is Brian Doe and writing the ground operations for these
every project in this region of Kenya.
What we're trying to do here is convert all conventional bikes
from petrol engines to electric motors.
Beyond just getting from place to place motor bikes are key to
generating income in this region. They're often used as taxi
vehicles or for transporting goods to market. And while making
the switch from gas to electric is obviously cleaner. There are
some more tangible benefits as well.
Maintaining electric bikes is way more cheaper than maintaining
a conventional bike in terms of servicing electric vehicles.
They have fewer moving parts. They don't require oil you know
here. People are spending around 10 U.S. dollars every two weeks
for the maintenance costs. So if you can save somebody one or
two dollars a day it's a very very big deal.
It's still early days for many great companies like Power Hive.
And it remains to be seen how big the industry's impact can be.
A study by Bloomberg NRF found that electricity from solar
hybrid mini grids is still expensive for many rural customers
and the sector suffers from a lack of investment. Meanwhile
large scale renewables are booming. Bulk solar and wind are the
most competitive new sources of energy and most of the world
today.
But with hundreds of millions of people still living beyond the
reach of major grids there's a massive opportunity to improve
lives without the climate. Paying the cost.
Our business model if it works can really change what
development means. And what we're trying to do is create a model
that can be deployed anywhere in rural communities across the
globe.
We have hundreds of millions of people that are going to be
joining the modern economy and these customers cannot do so in a
carbon unfriendly way. And here in Kenya we're showing that you
can sort of trade this model which we hope is actually going to
serve Africa for generations.
That's it for this week's edition. But keep the conversation
going. Follow us on Twitter at Climate I'm clothing line. This
is Bloomberg Daybreak.